Spending some time swimming in warm ocean
waters this summer?
You could be bathing in a sea of flesh eating
bacteria.
Hey I’m Carin for DNews and today I’ve
got a warning for folks hitting the beach
in any of the Gulf Coast states.
The health department in Sarasota, Florida
has confirmed that infection by the bacterium
Vibrio vulnificus is responsible for at least
one recent death there.
In fact, it’s responsible for 10 deaths
so far this year.
According to a study in the journal Clinical
Infectious Diseases 100 people are infected
each year, resulting in approximately 50 deaths.
This bacterium is particularly harmful because
it can infect us in two different ways.
First, we can contract it by eating raw or
undercooked seafood like oysters, and second,
it can invade our bodies through pre-existing
lesions - cuts, scrapes, blisters.
Once you get infected, you will feel the symptoms
right away and they are violent.
If ingested, the bacterium causes severe stomach
ache, vomiting, diarhhea and septicemia - a
life-threatening condition that worsens extremely
quickly.
If the Vibrio bacteria are contracted through
a skin lesion, wound infection can cause tissue
breakdown, resulting in large disfiguring
ulcers that require skin grafts or even limb
amputation.
In both cases immediate treatment with antibiotics
is critical, patients not treated for 3 days
after being infected have a death rate of
100%.
Now, why isn’t the world in a mass panic
over this deadly bacteria?
Well, it’s actually a normal part of the
microbial communities in most tropical coastal
waters.
But having skin lesions puts you at a much
greater risk of contracting an infection.
If you have an open sore of any kind, it’s
not a great idea to go swimming in Sarasota
right now.
If you do have a cut or you get one from a
sharp coral or sea urchin spine - disinfect
it right away!
And, if you’re a connoisseur of raw oysters,
it may be a good idea to focus on ones from
cooler Northern climates.
Vigilance is key in preventing an infection
by this bacteria.
In addition, experts note that those with
compromised immune systems and notably with
liver disease, are much more likely to contract
an infection than healthy individuals.
What makes the bacteria so lethal is a toxin
located in its cell walls.
It’s called a lipopolysaccharide or LPS,
and interestingly, females are protected against
its effects by the production of estrogen.
Almost all reported cases of infection by
Vibrio bacteria are in males, not females.
Studies looking at the effects of LPS done
in rats showed a rapid death rate for males
but not females; however, when females had
their ovaries removed both sexes exhibited
the same death rates.
In addition to the LPS, the bacteria contain
a number of other compounds that facilitate
its virulence and infection rate, including
numerous tissue degrading enzymes.
Vibrio bacteria are especially virulent in
the warm summer months, they actually go into
a more dormant state when water temperatures
are cooler.
Because they thrive in warm waters, overall
increases in ocean temperatures due to global
warming means that their ranges are expanding.
As temperatures continue to climb, scientists
expect a parallel increase in death rate caused
by Vibrio-related infections.
Do you think that risk of a potentially deadly
bacteria will keep you out of the water?
Let us know in the comments below and keep
coming back for more DNews every day of the
week.